what are your thoughts
on uh the pivot that jake paul
and his brother have done in the
fighting i think it's amazing i think
it's incredible
legendary it is they're my legendary
people right there
when jake paul ran up on um conor
mcgregor
gregor's boy the other day in the back
of the truck throwing [ __ ] at him i was
like this kid
is a genius he's gonna make conor
mcgregor fight him because nobody ever
would have thought that that would
happen but i feel like it has to happen
now
this dude's trolling him so hard he's
he's they're they're doing great work
would you fight
if if the bag was right would you go and
get in the ring
yes if the bag is right if i'm do you
know how much money they made
yes that i don't know i don't know how
much money they made because i know
me on the undercard i want somebody to
put me on on the cardboard that's
i'm with it i'm definitely would you
take the jake paul fade though
yeah for the bag yeah you'd be
i used to box in four years okay so i
don't know you can actually fight yeah i
can actually fight
i'm like naked i get in there yeah nate
robinson just didn't know how to box
yeah that was rough to watch but boxing
at the end of the day boxing is a sport
you know what i mean it's just a
strategy it's not but jake paul is
obviously getting better yeah of course
he's been boxing for three years
it's a lot of experience that come with
that so i think when you mix like his
i kind of think yeah he might beat
connor no
no no no no come on man no cap come on
man
his brother's gonna get washed i guess i
mean come on no man
listen i don't know if you know but nate
robinson is
this [ __ ] is dunking at five six he's a
tiny man
and he put him to sleep yeah but he's
bro that's that
i get what you said but it's just like
jake you can't discredit jake paul it's
not like a scrawny like little dude when
that fight started
you did not think jake paul was going to
sleep that [ __ ] like that i won
money i bet on jake paul i want to tell
you but she wasn't my bookie
but you ain't think he was going to
sleep is it i thought it was going to be
i actually
thought it was going to be ugly
because if you look at them next to each
other you're like damn nate robinson's
so
small bro and like this kid you know has
been fighting he trained with shane
mosley and
like you know those guys pretty well the
paul's yeah they're cool as [ __ ]
you know yeah i feel like they they they
probably have a bit of a you know
there's probably you know everybody's
got misconceptions about them
yeah no i don't think it's cool as hell
smart people